once i see that he's starting to fall
back a little bit i see rudy's speed in
the background you know kind of speeding
up i can tell that
rudy's got the edge on him that's my cue
to throw the lob
what's up guys this is mike conley and
i'm gonna take you through the breakdown
what makes me one of the best point
guards in the nba
i play more of a game that's patient
it's reactive whatever you give me i
take advantage of
the guy defending you kind of draped
over you just getting him
on your hip a little bit to where you
you control his body a little bit more
and you're in control of the action
it might look like you're pressured and
it feels like a pressure situation but
you're truly in complete control you see
rudy there he doesn't set
the screen he instead dives straight
down the gut
as soon as his man commits a little bit
into coverage
i read it right away like i as soon as i
saw him
that one you kind of just you know
you're going to thread the needle he
knows he's going to catch it and have a
two-step
to the rim either dunk or layup and it's
on him to finish it
these metrics have helped me just
understand when i'm watching the film
now
just knowing that these are situations
where hey they're all over me
and we're still able to make this play
how can we get
myself into a situation where i can
create a little bit more space
get this guy off my back not have to be
put into a situation where
i can potentially make a mistake this
one is a a typical one-two play for us
for me and rudy it's a we call a hip
screen side
side pick-and-roll i always read the the
guy guarding me what he's gonna do go
over under if he goes under i shoot it
if he goes over
i then keep my dribble and play my way
into the paint
secondly i look at the big and if he's
dropping back or if he's pushing up once
i see
that he's starting to fall back a little
bit i see rudy's speed in the background
you know kind of speeding up i can tell
that rudy's got the edge on him that's
my cue to throw the lob when i get the
ball i see that i have
the advantage on the guy guard me so
like at that point i
don't worry about the guy who's guarding
me next is the guy
who's helping from the top of the key i
see him kind of fake stunt
to try to you know get back to the
shooter and at that point
my eyes are either first at that big
that's guarding rudy seeing if he comes
up or not because if he does i'm
throwing it immediately
if he starts to fall back a little bit
like initially right at that free throw
line point
i automatically look at the corner to
see if
maybe that corner guys man has helped
over
also to help over on the lob on rudy if
he doesn't move like he doesn't
like he does in this place i know that's
just a two-man game
that's an almost impossible play to stop
things you work on
you try to work on at a young age is
reading the defender guarding a guy on a
pin down in this case is donovan
they trail and donovan's looking to curl
that screen and get downhill
and put himself in that position where
he forces the big to make a decision
in this case the guard shoots the gap by
the screen
and donovan's anticipating it and so am
i
as soon as he does rudy being the
screener that he is he's smart enough to
flip it really quickly
catch a piece of him i'm able to throw
the ball to a spot
i'm just throwing it to an area where i
know that he's going to kind of get
close to
makes the catch and that's the teed up
pw3 for
you know our best guys we just try to
find an advantage
and play advantage basketball some days
we create
what we call the blender where the
ball's just moving and moving moving
we were able to throw it around swing it
swing it drive it again
then swing it again by that time
the team is kind of checked out and then
somebody gets open shot
this whole three-point barrage thing is
new to me too i'm still learning it
everybody's got this green light i've
been in league for so long that
when i first came in it was a lot of
post up play shoot i played against shaq
we were all trying to be a threat five
threats on the court
it makes it extremely tough and puts a
lot of pressure on defenses to have to
guard
everybody when that happens the
efficiency pops up
it'll just happen organically guys are
turning down
good shots for great shots and it's
contagious that's what makes us
special right now i appreciate you
sitting here watching my film session on
the breakdown
uh gave you a little bit of what i like
to do and how i read different coverages
and the pick and roll and
hopefully you learned something from it
and uh hopefully i'll see you guys in
the court
thanks